that's all thanks for putting up with me
see you on the flip side yo dog skillet
I'm so hilarious anyway I wonder how
this week's video is doing it's time hey
a bazillion views already
fancy that wait why are there so many
dislikes what the hell dude that's so
disgusting I just threw up in my mouth
mole please don't ever show us that
again oh my god so gross dislike
unsubscribe bus what are you talking
about wait what's that
there oh I know I'll enhance it ah I
don't believe it I accidentally left a
topless picture of myself open on the
computer screen in the background for
the entire video I wasn't even there in
the first place I no wonder people are
completely outraged this is without a
doubt the biggest up I've ever made
if only there was something I could do
about it
[Music]
it's time for another challenge Charlie
hello there you person today I've been
challenged by Sonya sub attina to make a
video about time travel now currently
traveling through time anything other
than the normal pace the rule used to
isn't possible I mean yes I can
time-travel of course with my magical
kazoo of time but for everyone else
unfortunately you can't
but even though humanity can't time
travel just yet it is still fun to think
about what would happen if we could and
there are a number of different ideas as
to what the rules of time-travel would
be for example one idea is that of a
flexible timeline that can be re-written
at will or the Back to the Future model
say that I decide to eat the last cookie
and it's so bloody delicious that by the
time I'm done I decide to go back in
time and eat the last cookie again
however my decision to go back in time
was based on me being able to eat the
last cookie in the first place and so
now that future me is eatin the cookie
before past me has had a chance to I've
changed the course of history and
created a paradox
oh hey where's my cookie another idea is
that of a single fixed timeline that
can't be altered a tool or the Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban model
imagine that this time I come home and
find to my surprise a brand new batch of
delicious cookies and I eat them all by
myself once I'm done I naturally want
some more and so I decide to beg my own
but once I've made them I become
confused as to who made the original
cookies in the first place and then I
realized that the cookies I've just made
are identical to the ones I ate once I
got home and so I go back in time and
place the cookies where I originally
found them ready for the past version of
me to enjoy oh yay cookies so even
though there is still time travel
involved the timeline is completely
consistent with itself and so there are
no paradoxes but as interesting as
time-travel is in a fictional sense in
my view it becomes much more interesting
when you find out about the fact that
theoretically it's actually possible if
you've experienced as much science
fiction as I have then at some point you
probably come across the term wormhole
but what you might not know is the
physics does actually allow the
possibility of real wormholes the idea
is that in the world that we live in
space and time are intrinsically linked
into something called space-time and if
we take our three-dimensional universe
represented here by this 2d piece of
paper and we bend our universe into an
invisible fourth dimension so that two
different bits of space-time are pressed
together the point at which these two
different bits of space-time meet is a
wormhole this is a wormhole the only
slight problem is that in order for
someone to be able to go through a
wormhole to travel from one point in
space-time to another we would need an
amount of energy comparable to a star
exploding which is quite a lot of energy
but it is still allowed by the laws of
physics there is currently no rule
saying that we could not time travel
time travel is not impossible it's just
very
very improbable I will leave you with
that thank you for watching my video
about time travel I hope it was both fun
and informative goodbye oh my god
you look awfully familiar it's me
Charlie I am you from the future that's
funny because I just finished making a
video about time travel that's why I'm
here there's a serious problem with our
new video you or well we accidentally
left a topless picture of ourselves open
on the computer screen in the background
for the entire video Oh God thank
goodness you told me why was it even
there in the first place
Oh everyone would have unsubscribed if
they'd saw that yeah they didn't
subscribe actually Wow well I better
refill my video then but wait what time
travel rules are we following what
happens to oh well at least now nobody
on the internet is ever going to see a
topless picture of me hey I'm sorry for
taking off my t-shirt and rubbing my
nipples you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
yeah it didn't subscribe actually you
think they couldn't get another bit of
this but apparently it's disgusting